and you mind if I join you
hey that dude oh sorry you not yeah owes
me have you kind of beat it cuz you're a
distraction what brings you down here go
on vacation here with your boyfriend no
I'm just here with them
my mom name is why are you dressed like
powder this song is very dangerous mom
it feels like you're putting it on just
here when you need it here
let's go out today there are makeup
boobs we're going out Emily I am NOT
going out at night everything shouldn't
be so scary oh wait damn well should one
in for tourists are kidnapped not true 1
2 3
somebody's missing I'm drinking was a
man in a foreign country is a smart
responsible thing to do we need an
amazing adventure where the hell are we
is scenic route
what's up in the Marigny who says I
already am before you told me one two
three change it I will get up out of
here I need to believe in me judging may
be enough guys okay
I saw his brains I need your help mom
and I got kidnapped State Department my
mom and sister they've been taken I
imagine you have commando squad for
underground criminals who were tried for
a crime they didn't commit
cells ip8 is the a-team is do you have
an eight-team just listen to you this is
great
you messed with the wrong [ __ ] yeah
go I'm gonna count down I'm gonna do it
this 199
you